bonjour alain durand bonjour et merci
d'être en direct ce matin sur rtl france
pour ce pour parler d'abord de dos au
salon qui se tient hongrie qui fait
figure un peu d'exception en europe
d'ailleurs un grand salon international
pour promouvoir la tradition de la
chasse qu'en pensez vous est ce que vous
avez eu connaissance de ce salon
j'ai eu connaissance de ce salon puisque
gt gt à budapest la semaine dernière 2
j'ai passé trois quatre jours à budapest
et j'ai visité cette exposition mondiale
de 2,2 la nature puisqu'elle s'était en
gare de jacques anthian anniversaire
d'une exposition qui avait déjà eu lieu
sur ce sujet où l'arena te retrouver
toutes les activités chasse est aussi
géré toutes et toutes les pratiques qui
se passe dans tous les pays d'europe
voir tous les pays du monde moi alors
justement à un gigantesque salon de la
chasse alors que les questions autour de
cette tradition divise aujourd'hui on au
sein de l'europe à ce que la chasse au
niveau européen est de plus en plus
menacée pour vous
la chasse n'est pas menacée la chasse il
faut qu'on m'explique
on a fait déjà des vhu france et d un
sondage de l'ifop qui montre bien que
les majorité de français qui sait au
bond qui sont pas opposés farouchement
la chance ils veulent simplement savoir
comment ça se passe et qu'on leur
explique cette problématique on la rend
compte dans tous les pays européens
puisque je suis également à la fin ce
qui est la fédération des associations
de chasseurs ou bien on retrouve
toujours recette cette difficulté à
pouvoir expliquer de nous nos activités
en hongrie au cir même le vice-premier
ministre nous a expliqué qu'il était
confronté lui aussi à ces problématiques
à ses deux divisions un peu entre le
entre les urbains et les ruraux si on
veut simplifier mais je pense que c'est
une chose qui va ce qui va se se régler
rapidement puisque lorsqu'on aura bien
expliquer aux citoyens français ou
européens et que la pratique de la
chasse n'est pas une deux une activité
contraire et qui détruit la biodiversité
comme on peut nous faire croire au
contraire la chasse j'irai une solution
pour la biodiversité la conservation de
de la nature des espèces une grande
manifestation la semaine dernière des
chasseurs français ce que le discours de
faire comprendre aux français que la
chasse n'est pas destructrice de la
biodiversité est audible selon vous
oui les grandes manifestations jeu j
participer puisque mans j'étais sûre peu
dé temps en normandie j'étais à caen
cette manifestation a été déclenchée par
la suppression d'un autre conseil d'état
en france de deux chasses
traditionnelles
et cette décision du conseil d'état nous
a semblé complètement
insupportable puisque depuis 20 ans il
autoriser ces chassés de la peinture et
d'un seul coup il est supprimé c'est ce
qui a fait monter la colère des
chasseurs mais au-delà de cette
suppression de chasse traditionnelle ou
suspensions plutôt puisque nous avons
réagi et que notre ministre de tutelle a
refait une demande de d'ouverture de ces
chasses traditionnelles on verra ce riz
le conseil d'état dira mais au-delà de
ça si vous voulez y a il ya une
inquiétude du monde du monde de la
chasse
2 une suite par rapport à ce qui se
prépare parfois dans certaines de
législation française notamment à propos
du du du bien-être animal parce
qu'aujourd'hui on nous accuse de tous
les maux nous accuse maltraiter nos
chiens vous accuse de maltraiter nos
chevaux lorsque nous faisons de la
chasse à courre etc alors ça devient
très très compliqué mais nous sommes
assez optimistes si nous allons
continuer mais le a expliqué à expliquer
ce qu'est la chasse est effectivement ce
qu'elle apporte à la nature est la pire
des ursidés parce que je crois qu'ils
prennent plus de 3 milliards d'euros que
les chasseurs apporte en termes
d'activités bénévoles sur l'entretien
des espaces et de la nature trapé salle
les citoyens livre vous des méthodes de
montrer du doigt en france notamment les
méthodes les méthodes de chasse
traditionnelle bruxelles aussi raconté
de 2023 de 2023 veut interdire
l'utilisation de munitions en plomb
elles sont d'ailleurs interdite dans
toutes les eaux de humides en europe
quels types d'impacts va avoir ce cette
décision
l'utilisation du plomb l'interdiction
d'utilisation du plomb sur sur les zones
et en direction des zones humides existe
déjà en france donc ce ne sera pas une
nouveauté pour nous bon le problème
c'est l'extension de l'arrêt de ces
munitions pour les autres chats se en
plaine au bois etc alors bien sûr il y
aura une incidence l'incident si vous
voulez elle va se produire sur le les
fusils que nous possédons ce que tous
les fusils ne sont pas adaptés à
l'utilisation d'autres d'autres
cartouches de celle au plomb si on doit
utiliser de la grenaille d'acier et les
sur canon un certain nombre d'armes
anciennes ceux qui possèdent encore les
fusils du grand père etc ça posera un
problème sauf si sauf si les fabricants
de cartouches trouve des munitions qui
soit compatible avec celle avec ses 1 or
actuellement eux je sais que si ces
professionnels de la de l'arbre il
travaille là dessus parce que ça veut
dire aussi que si demain certains noms
aux deux cuisines peuvent pas être
utilisés à nombre de chasseurs arrêtons
de châssis il ya aussi sera l'impact
économique sur 600 cartouches et les
fabricants de cartouches etc
quelle est la suite vous restez
mobilisés à une manifestation est prévue
pour mars l'an prochain les espagnols
aussi ont manifesté bientôt
baisser en mars prochain c'est une
manifestation qui est prévue à paris de
l'ensemble du monde de la chasse
française
mêmes pulsions parler des espagnols je
dois aussi vous signaler c'est peut-être
un scoop pour vous qu il y aura
probablement en septembre 2022 une
manifestation à bruxelles ne pour
rencontrer les députés du parlement et
la commission européenne
merci beaucoup alain durand suivra ça
bien évidemment de de près je le
rappelle vous êtes vice président
délégué de la fédération nationale des
chasseurs